[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the lab basically where we do
all of our all of our mixing and
polishing so as you can probably tell
we've mixed a few batches of blood on
this counter but I can take you through
a batch if you like most of your
run-of-the-mill Bloods start off with
corn syrup you know it gives it a little
viscosity if it was gonna be a regular
everyday blood we put some soap in it
because that helps it clean up really
like when you when you get in your
wardrobe or something it helps it wash
out if you were to just put color in
here right now it would kind of come out
looking like cherry cough syrup because
blood is a little opaque it's not
completely see-through so we we add an
opacifier to it to make it opaque before
we start to color it so basically what
you get is kind of this white looking
slurry then you can start to color we go
through a lot of food coloring obviously
the base is red now you're never really
gonna get to a really realistic blood
red with just red food color so what we
do is a little blue or black and then
that gives us a little depth so do you
know it looks more like your classic
classic blood Wow now we can take this
and take it out of here and do a little
something you like so we can we can do
the you know maybe a blood spray and
maybe
you know the classic blow out the back
your head on the wall kind of thank for
this like sometimes you know you'd hide
them behind somebody and then you know
at the moment where they get shot in the
head then splat against wall now if we
do more pressure than it's a little more
violent so this is going to be more
directed
[Music]
that's for when you get sliced in the
neck and spray it sprays out so if
you're doing blood on a floor that you
can't really get blood on because it's
going to stain or on carpet or you know
stuff like that then we then we make
these rubber ones that we we can just
throw down on the floor and then pick up
and go away
[Music]